عند حلول الظلام في أحد الأحياء التي مزقتها الحرب في
مدينة أوندرمان بسيدني،
تشاهد فيديو تصوير حراري
يصور قوات عسكرية مجهزة
بمعدات عالية التقنية أكثر تطورًا بكثير
مما أظهره السنة حتى
الآن
وهنا سلسلة من
الضربات النهارية عالية الدقة تمطر  من
السماء في نفس المدينة وما حولها، ضربت
أهدافًا تدعمها
مجموعة المرتزقة الروسية الأب في السودان،
وقال مصدر عسكري أوكراني لشبكة CNN إن هذا من
عمل جيش أجنبي،
وسأل عما إذا كانوا سيقولون بشكل
لا لبس فيه أن كييف كانت وراء
الهجمات، ولم يقل المصدر سوى  يقول إن
الخدمات الخاصة الأوكرانية كانت
مسؤولة على الأرجح، وهو ما سيشكل
توسعًا كبيرًا ويبقي مسرح
الحرب ضد موسكو.
كشفت تحقيقات CNN السابقة أن
قوات الدعم السريع شبه العسكرية التابعة لقوات الدعم السريع (RSF) تحظى بدعم كبير من
فاغنر أثناء قتالهم للجيش السني في
حرب من أجل الهيمنة.
حصلت CNN على سلسلة من مقاطع الفيديو
للعملية تظهر 14 غارة مختلفة
على أسلحة ومعدات قوات الدعم السريع التي يعتقد أن فاغنر
قدمتها. وقد
حددنا سبعة مواقع مختلفة
لضربات الطائرات بدون طيار في معقل قوات الدعم السريع
الذي أصبح نقطة محورية
في الصراع وقمنا بتحديد الموقع الجغرافي.
لقطات الغارة الليلية على نفس
المدينة من خلال تحديد المباني التي تظهر
هنا، تم بالفعل تحرير فيديو الطائرة بدون طيار الذي حصلت عليه CNN،
ولكن لا تزال هناك أدلة حول
هوية أولئك الذين يقفون وراء
الهجمات، والنص الموجود على شاشة
وحدة تحكم الطائرة بدون طيار الذي يظهر هنا باللغة الأوكرانية
اضغط لبدء تسجيل هذه
الطائرات بدون طيار المتاحة تجاريًا والتي تستخدم على نطاق واسع
من قبل القوات الأوكرانية،
ولديها أقصى نطاق لنقل الفيديو
يبلغ حوالي تسعة أميال، مما يعني أنه
يمكننا معرفة أن طياري الطائرات بدون طيار
كانوا في السودان بالقرب من السودان،
وهو تكتيك شائع في أوكرانيا ولكن ليس
كذلك  وقال خبراء الطائرات بدون طيار في السودان، الذين استشارتهم شبكة
CNN، إن هذه هي المرة الأولى التي
يتم فيها نشر طائرات بدون طيار مثل هذه
بهذه الطريقة في أفريقيا،
وشاركت CNN مقاطع الفيديو مع مصدر رفيع المستوى
في الجيش السوداني للتعليق، والذي
قال إنه ليس لديه علم
بعملية أوكرانية في السودان.  السودان ولم
يصدق أن هذا صحيح.
أصبح السودان متورطًا في حرب روسيا
ضد أوكرانيا العام الماضي على الرغم من كونه على بعد
آلاف الأميال من خط المواجهة
عندما أبلغنا أن شركة فاغنر استغلت
موارد الذهب في السودان للمساعدة في تمويل
جهود حرب موسكو في أوكرانيا
للتحايل على العقوبات الأمريكية على روسيا
بعد  سقطت طائرة تقل زعيم فاغنر،
يفغيني براغوشان، على الأرض
أواخر الشهر الماضي، يعتقد الكثيرون أن
نفوذ فاغنر سوف ينحسر، لكن
العكس تمامًا هو ما حدث، حيث
قال المبلغون عن المخالفات العسكرية في عدد من الدول الأفريقية لشبكة CNN إن
الكرملين يعزز سلطته على
شبكات فاغنر في وسط البلاد.
جمهورية أفريقيا في السودان وليبيا ومالي،
والآن توسعت هذه الشبكة بشكل
أكبر هذه المرة في تشاد. وقد
تأثرت تشاد بالفعل بالقتال الدائر في
السودان المجاور، ومع ذلك فقد ظهرت
كنقطة عبور رئيسية للإمدادات إلى
قوات الدعم السريع في
الجزء السوداني.  عن توسع
النفوذ الروسي في أفريقيا، بالرجوع إلى
شهادة مصادر استخباراتية وعسكرية
نشطة في المنطقة من خلال
صور الأقمار الصناعية، كشفت شبكة CNN عن
أدلة على أن أسلحة فاغنر عبرت
عبر تشاد خلال الأسبوعين الماضيين
للوصول إلى قاعدة عسكرية لقوات الدعم السريع في السودان
إذا كنت  انظر عن كثب، يمكنك رؤية أكثر من
مائة مركبة، بما في ذلك عشرات
الشاحنات في القاعدة، مما يدل على أن الإمدادات التي
قدمتها روسيا فاغنر، ومواصلة
الضربة على القوات المدعومة من فاغنر في
السودان ستشكل ضربة لموسكو
إذا كانت أوكرانيا هي التي ستزيد
من المخاطر  أولئك المستعدون لقبول
دعم فاغنر في المستقبل هو درس
يوضح الثمن الذي قد
يضطرون إلى دفعه مقابل التعاون مع
روسيا وسي
إن إن وجامانا تشاد.